Florida Governor Rick Scott is with us
now on the phone as he wait makes his
way to the keys to survey the damage
governor Scott thank you so much for
joining us I know as you're there that
in the keys that's now being described
as a looming humanitarian crisis are you
concerned that some Floridians there are
still trapped in their homes well we're
going to find out we've got search and
rescue teams you know going down there
we've got going to Jacksonville you know
the storm Stono state we're seeing
flooding and storm surge in the
Northeast Florida area I hope everybody
continues to pray for our state but I'll
be going down there with the Coast Guard
in just a few minutes we're going to
assess all the geese we'll focus on to
make sure everybody survives this and
we're you know we've got a great support
from the president I talked to three
times yesterday I talked to Brock long
all day yesterday an administrator FEMA
and today I've been reaching out and
learning more from our sheriff's our
first responders around and we clearly
have in we go what we've got a lot of
power out I want everybody to think
about staying safe
a lot of downed power lines we've got a
lot of closed roads our power companies
are getting out there to please get the
power back on our Transportation
Department is getting out there cleaning
the roads and the locals are doing the
same thing the president is provided
that he can provide every bit of support
we need so we're all given we're all
gonna work to keep everybody live and
get everybody back to normal as quickly
as possible unfortunately we've got a
lot of damage in our state so governor
what's the most important thing you want
people to know right now and what's at
the top of your to-do list well the big
thing is it's a disaster area the first
is the ease if I'm not exactly what they
need I've been talking to individual
families I want to make sure that
anybody needs to be rescued whether it's
in the cage or anyplace else
absolutely we don't spare one expense to
say every lines in this thing we're
sitting the rescue teams over to the
Jacksonville area because we know we're
getting flooding there so the big thing
is still keep everybody alive and then
everybody's got to take the time this is
a very tough time because you're gonna
you're gonna be out of power for a while
our roads are not clear yet and
a lot of down Caroline I want everybody
remember stay safe
governor how long will it take to get
the power back up we'll find out as they
cruise cool out we we pre-positioned and
assets we have over 23,000 individuals
come into our state to help prepare our
utilities so we're starting to give
testament that talk to the biggest
utilities company already in the state
they had lots of trucks in already pre
position down in the horizontal areas
they're getting those out all they're
getting them all across the state now
fast as they can
we'll provide law enforcement exports to
happen to get their vehicles out there
which so we're gonna do everything again
you the time back to possible can you
drive to Key West we right now we are SN
a few Matt that's one thing we're gonna
be doing by doing when we go get on
there we've got teams going from Key
West North than going from Miami South
to make sure all those bridges are good
we have you know it's over 56 bridges
we've got to make sure every bridge it's
safe and passable we're also working to
get our ports open so when you steal
back into the state as you know we we
were struggling to keep enough fuel in
the state per citizen
so we've got some fuel in our in our on
big in Port Campbell Bay and Port
Everglades down so far though but we
need to get the tankers in here as fast
as we can all right governor Scott thank
you very much for taking the time
governor Scott reporting to us from the
road thanks a lot